investigation into hundreds of deaths
linked to a doomsday cult as widening
Kenyan police say they've now recovered
the bodies of more than 200 people who
were members of a cult in a remote
Forest survivors say Pastor Paul
McKenzie and fengay ordered his
followers to starve themselves to death
when Malcolm Webb joins me live from
malindi in eastern Kenya and Malcolm
what stage has the investigation aired
at at the moment how much progress has
been made
from the last 24 hours police have said
that one more suspect has been arrested
being the number of arrests to 34 and in
the last few hours police from the
anti-terror unit have been searching the
premises of a vast super Church
belonging to another Evangelical pastor
called Ezekiel adero they're looking
into possible connections between him
and the cult leader Paul McKenzie
meanwhile people are still being found
alive others are still thought to be
alive in the bush some of them belonging
to the militia that it's widely reported
regarding uh the Cults others who were
cult followers including four people who
were here in melindi hospital right now
being treated with symptoms of hunger
one of them in a critical condition
let's take a look at our report
survivors say children were starved
first and some were suffocated or buried
alive if they didn't die
women and men were to follow to try to
reach heaven before the end of the world
Evangelical Pastor Paul McKenzie and
tenge and his followers moved here to
the shackahola forest four years ago
we spoke to somebody who's worked at the
exhumation site but is not authorized to
talk
he told us about 70 or 80 bodies
appeared to not be part of the cult
there's a place where we found many
graves together concealed under recently
planted vegetables those many bodies
were wrapped in a different way the
bodies of people from there were
normally wrapped in just the bed sheets
these ones were wrapped tightly and some
with straps around the necks as if for
carrying them
Mackenzie used to preach at his church
in the town of malindi he also had a TV
station and a YouTube channel
he's now in custody awaiting charges
he's been arrested and released several
times before even after his followers
started dying many people here say he
was paying off the police in malindi the
officers in charge have been transferred
come
received
investigators say he had business
dealings with this man another preacher
called Ezekiel addero thousands of
people come to his nearby church every
week right
in this video a woman says her ovaries
were removed for cancer treatment and
then reappeared after she drank blessed
water which Ezekiel sells
his rapidly growing Church appears to
have made a large amount of money in a
short time police records show that not
everyone who comes here leaves alive the
church premises are vast they include
two Banks here there's a shopping mall
and a fuel station under construction
there's also a hotel that houses the
sick police say they're investigating
cases of people who've died in here
whose bodies they say may be among those
buried in shakahola forest
Ezekiel was arrested last month but has
since been released on bail his bank
accounts were briefly Frozen his lawyers
deny all allegations and say he was not
involved in the cult
some people are calling for the growing
number of churches in Kenya to be
regulated
a committee of senators is gathering
views on how that could be done how do
we protect our country
from unnecessary suffering
which is brought by people who are
misusing the freedom of
worship that is guaranteed in the
Constitution
constitutional rights present One
Challenge political power presents
another some of the preachers have
popularity that politicians long for and
they work together
families of the hundreds of people still
missing are waiting to see if all the
questions about the bodies in shakahola
will be answered it's clear if the
extent of McKenzie's networks will ever
be revealed or if the most powerful
people involved will ever be held to
account
Malcolm Webb Al Jazeera kilifi County
Kenya